hi everyone
it's been 10 years in the making but
george r.r martin has made progress on
winds of winter
even if that progress has been slowed up
by his other projects
here's the latest update
martin has updated fans on his blog
about progress on various things he's
working on which includes winds of
winter the penultimate book in the
songs of ice and fire series
unfortunately the update doesn't give a
release date but reassured fans that the
book is being worked on
the author joked about the fact that he
hadn't been working on the railroad
despite an ongoing project to open a
restored 19th century railway called sky
railway in martin's home state of new
mexico which will run between santa fe
and lammy
instead he wrote that he's been working
on the massively anticipated book which
will be his first in the acclaimed
series since a game of thrones first
aired on hbo in 2011.
martin purchased the railway in 2020
with a group of business partners
on top of his railway martin also
revealed other projects that made
writing the book more challenging
he revealed that he's a prolific
executive producer on shows like dark
wins for amc joker town for peacock and
who fears death for hbo amongst others
it's clear that the various meetings for
these shows are taking up a lot of his
time
there have been hints by the author in
other blog posts that he may help write
some episodes for the upcoming game of
thrones prequel house of the dragon
which is based on martin's fire and
blood
if he does then expect even more delays
on winds of winter
while this book remains george r.r
martin's current literary project he's
already made plans to pen several other
stories in the future
a fourth dunk and eggs short story will
follow before martin completes the a
song of ice and fire series
he'll sandwich that with a fifth dunkin
egg story before moving on to fire and
blood volume 2.
clearly all this planning has also
interfered with progress on his current
work but it appears as though movement
is there with the book we're all waiting
for and a release date is just around
the corner